hi everyone it's Jerry I am going to
late join an hourly super Blitz Arena
I ran a stream earlier today
without my mic I had some issues but I
sorted them out
so this is a bit of a
check
mic check one two
okay we have a
Dutch
allow me to get in this E5 move
I think I should jump this opportunity
and maybe even go further
yeah hold off I think
I may be pushing it a bit too far it'll
be
challenged with D6 so
I like my position
it's healthy group of three pawns and
I'm gonna still stick with this
maintaining the tension on e4
Bishop G5 will almost certainly be
questioned right away
let me just sit
or
no let me go ahead and provoke a
weakness Maybe
yeah I'll do it like this because now
maybe one of these two jumps
G6 is a bit soft
where's this Knight going okay
it's not quite ready to jump here
all right let's go with this Rook uh
I'll go with this one I don't know I
have some concern over this maybe
possibly The Rook getting stuck there
on the other hand if you go with this
then you're more secure enough too so
it's a little bit of a tough call
but in this situation not a tough call I
have a nice double attack
okay
I could go ahead and take on G6 because
I am on this Knight in the end
um
yeah let's do that
this Knight is a little jumpy okay go to
F4
and what will I play
okay
just giving me a night here
it's going after a fork but I get two
minor pieces
yeah
all right
so let's pick off this guy
all right
and let's even go for this first
probably getting mated if you tried it
save the night now
check here there's too many pieces
so considering something else this
hey this I didn't expect
it should just be up the exchange
shortly
or I'm sorry not the exchange I should
just be up now a full peace
go ahead and collect this Knight
clean can't go too far
that's more than that it's the Knight
and two pawns but now
just adding to the material advantage
just want to be a trading machine
okay
we continue
I'll go here
many ways to do it
go after the weak link
yeah let's just
keep it Ultra simple
I guess they're just playing for time
here but
20 seconds is a lot
no stalemate issues
might get the pawn
mate they still have a pawn move
let's see who we get next all right
250 are in there
someone is 13 now okay
round number two Michelangelo
from Peru
all right Sicilian land
hmm
no I got D6
thinking keto all right I've been
messing around a bit with
this H pawn move
holding off I'm bringing the Knight
there
support it
okay
let's put this guy here first I like
keeping the tension
this diagonals opened up
um
probably is a little bit awkward to
play Rook to B1 I I imagine
I want to develop this guy here
expecting the bishop to
oh he's not going there straight away
let's get this one in
this is a little bit loose let's get
this defended first develop
Bishop there I'm ready to exchange and
maybe play Queen here
maybe bother
The Rook a bit more I'm also stopping
this break
uh maybe I'm not such a fan of having
this Knight here all right let's capture
is my queen gonna be scared if F takes
let's see if I put my queen here she
really can't be challenged
by this guy so fast
um
maybe thinking about this move or
maybe this one
hmm
okay
how to make a move I don't like that
Queen on F6 anymore
uh yeah maybe this guy should have been
deployed E7 and G6
all right let's let's undo a move I
don't think it's the end of the world
where's my king gonna go I'm not sure
maybe he's just gonna camp out
on his on home base for a bit
let's keep it a little closed I am
underdeveloped
I'm gonna go for a break you know what
let's let's stop this break I have a now
that they've kind of defined
the structure sum
let's be a maneuver
uh uh let's let's let's cancel out any
Knight F5 for right now
just want to hop in
need to take that night as soon as he
arrives there
cannot tolerate this guy in my house
on D5 F6
there's no night sacrifice on F5
covering it twice
so I'll have a strong Knight here
A5 A4
let me just keep my queen right where
she's at maybe they're
eyeing up a trick right here possibly
that could be a thing
you know what what's what's keeping me
from maybe playing this
let's go with this one
I'll have to babysit this soon
we need to be careful where she goes
I wonder if I have to play this you know
I like to have my king on G7
where'd she go the calculating Knight
takes here getting two pawns or
something
for the night
that can never be enough
what other move to consider only these
two right
okay back home she goes
uh let's sneak over
yeah
get my king on G7 I'm I'm feeling pretty
good
maybe this was the idea that I want to
be defended that's why
white opted for Queen E1 rather than E3
oh I just realized I'm way down on the
clock
let's get out of the f file
the pin considered G5
[Music]
um
who all gotta make a move
I'm ready for the opening up of this
position I want my knight right here
and it will get there actually
five of the time
trade everything
Superior minor piece
catching up on the clock now
all right gotta fly
that's a safe one to get in there
um I don't know if that's really the
correct break to go with
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna do I'm
going to promote this Pawn somewhat
I have a sneaky idea
that's the sneaky idea
huh fancy night
fancy night maneuver there in the end
okay
uh that one was weird
I guess if I'm gonna run with the H Pawn
like that and
develop my knight to H6 that's
that's what I get
a weird game if you play weird moves
all right let's go with the H Pawn again
yeah let's try it
this will be a theme
tournament
actually play with the H Pawn as much as
possible
so this is a little bit soft and now the
G5 Square
so is G4
let's carry on developing normally as if
these guys are back home
H2 H7 squares
prepping B5
not enough support for it yet I guess C6
is nearby
if I try to stop it then there's this
idea
Knight jumping into a weakened B4 Square
not quite
all right let's feed keto let's stop a
night jump here
prepping E5
there we go Queen side castles
nah
feel like it's
too easy to open up the position on the
queen side
all right let's start with this guy here
um I'm going with the queen Rook because
if if this then you know I still have
ideas too
to get in a break with F3
although I'm expecting that's going to
be a bit tricky to get in
because E3 is going to have some
pressure maybe I bring the bishop back
home let's try this
I really don't this may feel appealing
but there's that give and take I open up
my Bishop size but I open up a great
Square for this night
so I'm going to say no thanks to that
one well let's break with this F4 or F3
let's be consistent with my last move
now how to recapture
is a question for sure
hmm
initially I was thinking with the bishop
I probably should do that
um
wow was not expecting that one
Okay so
we're gonna chop away I guess
all right let's chop away they're giving
me the bishop pair
I'm gonna have no it's more than that
I'm gonna get a skewer in the end
hmm so they missed that this bishop
in the end arrives on F3
I'll take with the queen
first
and these fancy moves aren't anything I
could take one of the Rooks
so they just must have missed this one
in the end
and probably one of the Rooks has to go
back to E8
cash out I think so
save that pawn
I have a clock Edge
maybe more than an edge
okay that's a good move
that Knight's gonna be really powerful
right here let's let's see if I can get
this Pawn working or
oh
all right well this is
all right let's go with this
I think typically when you're down the
exchange
you'll want to keep
well your Dominator you want to keep
more pieces on board but also
um
am I trying to say
yeah The Rook you kind of need that Rook
to coordinate well with these
miners
so where to go with my king
all right let's let's start with this
one
still welcome a trade that was my day
with
bringing my Bishop back to just have it
defended
this tournament's flying by
um
night's so scary
it's ready to land a fork
I want to control them a little bit
now we can improve the king
I don't know if I could really make a
great break
yeah I've done a good job to not give
myself a
a great way to make a break
that night is ready to land a fork
all right I have to have to go for it
now
oh I thought the night was going to be a
pest
jumping to C2 and taking A3
the knight's a bit offside now
so to get a break in over here then
okay my king has improved quite a bit
so let's go hunting for The Rook Pond
the one that's going to be hardest to
track down
oh hang on
tricky nights man tricky nights
I didn't calculate this
I guess we're both cleaning
why not give a check
let's do it now
it's a bit lazy there
very
yeah again that was really lazy in the
end
um hmm that was really tricky I I won
the exchange but the structure was
static and difficult to open up
should have uh the the technique there
when I was up the exchange was not not
the best
all right we still have 30 minutes left
I got eight
okay I've been playing around with
Queen's game but accepted lately
and I've been getting some decent
positions
okay
so this is a this is the first square
that jumps to mind
when I see A4 in there
um
all right I guess what we're gonna take
and immediately make use of that Gap
and castle
okay let's get on the long diagonal
isolated Pawn
I want to have that under control for
sure
so there's no pin so
I mean I was keeping some options open
with my knight
if the bishop decided to go there I was
going to connect them
uh
now I'm thinking a bit more about this
one I don't I don't have to fear D5 push
anymore there isn't support
and also
I have another maneuver I could shoot
for with this guy
could pivot
what's that move about
I have enough support for that one right
okay
I'll keep it and keep it Dynamic I guess
oh I guess they just completely
miscalculated there
no they had a blind spot I guess
thinking that there was still a bishop
on C4 or something
I'm up a piece
centralized
nothing sophisticated let's keep put the
knights on
perfect squares
going after this guy
it's a little irritating but I
could afford to make these under
developing moves
paint off the piece let's get back to
an active Square component's moving fast
all right let's point it there King I'm
looking to lock down the the ABC files
definitely a fan of exchanges
stabilize the bishop don't be concerned
about double death Pawns
up the piece
put my king in a dark Square
trade trade trade
that's where we're at
can't really go anywhere else with the
Rook I have entry points covered
opponents in the tank
improve the king I like that idea
get off of a light Square okay now we
could hop to a weakness
can control the file now based on that
weakness
okay
we'll throw a check in there see where
the king wants to go
all right chance to undouble
Maybe
okay got a Pac-Man Rook
which one do I want
I'll go with this one
it might be something like this I'm
undermining of this configuration I
wanna
rule out any of that
King here guards everything
Bishop here guards everything and just
go hunting with this guy
it's the cleanest way I see forward here
offer trades
push the passers
oh I could have got the
the Rooks off a little bit sooner
time is not an issue here
no stalemates happening
okay
one of these
all right 24 is in first okay they
resigned
all right
19th 12 the fire first is 24.
okay
24 to go
SK
hmm
I remember that game let's try another
Queens
Gambit accepted
C5 right now
I've been playing it with this Knight
here first and then C5 but that might be
off the order because of E4
I don't think A3 is the
the most testing I guess A3 is designed
to secure the Knight
black is already comfortable maybe even
starts thinking about being better at
this point
we'll go here
it's unprotected but I don't think it's
exploitable
I'm ready to recapture this guy
releases the tension I like the Knight
Improvement second rank Knight comes a
fourth ranked Knight
and I think my queen likes this Square
best
King Rook is ready to play
let's hop here
okay Queen there or upon there Queen is
looking to go somewhere let's
go hunting for a bishop
I think gonna be successful
getting the dark Square Bishop
the same time I don't think I should be
too quick to capture
the bishop maybe maybe not
let's take here first
I could get the other Bishop if the
bishop captures
okay so maybe get the tempo against the
queen first
seems sensible
and then and then we capture the dark
Square Bishop
and then say mission accomplished with
the queen on B6 let's
see if we could
provoke a weakness
also maintaining control over the only
open file
not quite sure how to approach this
Maybe
maybe bishop here makes sense
I'm guessing they're going to be able to
exchange a light Square Bishop the light
Square Bishops and
I wouldn't really mind that let's go
with this one
here I don't think I mind that so
because this guy's in a spot well my
Bishop would be coordinated
with um
now let's do it like this
oh no let's go like that
yeah my my Bishop is coordinated well
with my structure
okay
on the night
these guys are offsetting one another
but I feel like I have the
the better play
let's just stop any H5 idea
um actually why didn't I take the Knight
I just said I was on the night
oh
okay
that was pretty bad
okay let's let's go for this
I'm on The Rook
so if Queen there take a rook
oh man a free night
I pointed out the threat
and then didn't do anything
you get myself into trouble there some
check and then a pin
you know what maybe I just repeat here
yeah
I don't think I had anything I missed my
chance at a free piece
okay
I like the opening there
I think it was a success
but again not 100 sure about playing in
night
D7
um B4 C5
thanks I think I think C5 is the correct
one
all right
let's go with this break
the Knight is put here and you don't get
this break in he could end up being kind
of silly
let's take with the bishop
Knight F3 Bishop D3 the pieces fall on
wonderful squares there might be some
sacrifices soon
on H7 that's a very slow move
all right
the H Pawn
wait isn't there a famous game or if
there's castles for me or king move for
me
night here is it
I have not calculated any of this I'm
eyeing up Queen H5
um
I don't know is this even working
let's just make a flashy looking move
I am threatening me now
night jump
Queen takes H7
these pieces are starting to overwhelm
black
did not see that one
okay
okay that's sneaky oh okay hang on for a
second thought I can move my knight
I was almost ready not to move my knight
this is the way
maintain my queen post
threaten the bishop threaten the rope
with my Bishop
and I'm threatening Mateen too
so even if this I have a main two how do
you stop me and two
this one
feels like it's gonna be me
even if this Knight is captured then you
have to deal with the Rook so it's like
one of these two are always going to be
in the game
exerting pressure get rid of this guy
this one
Springs to life
what to do
not easy
fifth ranked Knights
these guys are spectators
take a pawn
I'm not sure what to suggest here
I guess Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes
Knight it is
yeah let's take here first
and just take the Rook first why am I
not taking the Rook first
let's take the Rook first
oh my goodness I have a really good
continuation
it's going to be mate Pawn takes Bishop
will be met by check
and then Pawn takes Bishop for me
is there still something fancy like that
nearby
not quite
that would have been a nice finish
nice defensive move
do I just have to abandon
one for me
I guess I'm 31 seconds now
can't Castle queenside
okay
of the exchange
down a whole lot on the clock
you may have to be prepared to sack my
Bishop G6
they're in the tank
okay let's just take this guy out
swatch for any coordination on G2
there it is that was a main thread
prove the King end game control the
Knight
control the Knight with the bishop
I keep the structure as is
could have also grabbed the poem
I'm on the night don't forget it this
time
all right we got that one
as close to a nice finish there I think
H4 was unnecessary
the bishop went to E7 I think hop into
E5 straight away
and then look to get that Queen out
okay
we got two more games in
that's 16.
Michelangelo again let's try an E4 game
all right
that one
let's not be too quick to move this
Knight maybe F4 but when this guy's here
no thanks
simple development
I'm gonna stop the PIN
Castle
okay
right there I'm going to drop the bishop
back
okay
um
let's make this move right now actually
I'm looking for this break I'll have to
resolve the tension first
oh that's an interesting move
all right I don't want to allow the
Knight to take out my Bishop so
now let's take now
and
I'm gonna forget about the F4 breaking
try and shoot for the D4 break
jumping back and forth here with ideas
Knight is tactically vulnerable
Queen takes H5
some Knight could jump to F4 I always
have to be watching out for these
night sacrifices
so
put the Knight on a healthy Square
F3
hard to argue with that one
next up let's challenge the one that's
in my house straight away this guy's out
of play
I'm up a pond I wanna
eliminate all these
and any pieces that are
maybe even
hinting at some attack
some coordinated effort with the queen
and night
I am guarding G5 though
okay let's I'll take and then Step Up
expecting Queen F6
I may have missed play this now Queen F6
there's a
there's a knight takes H3 idea
okay
H4
let's call it H4
undermine
if this then I have to worry about the
queen
entering the scene and I can now start
thinking about these weaknesses or even
G3 but I I like hopping to this weakness
straight away
so watch out for one little check
okay let's get here straight away
the queen was ready to go here and
that should be avoided
now maybe I'm ready to scare the night
away
yeah let's scare the night away
H3 and then G4
looks a little scary but I think the
Knight is out of play
and yeah let's let's stay a little bit
more Central and now maybe go for this
break
yeah this Knight should be
a piece I could work around
pretty easily
okay my knight is defended
so I could take here
so I have to watch out for the queen
getting on this diagonal
and go here because on the capture I'm
targeting this
uh another thing I'm I'm forgetting is
that my queen and Knight are coordinated
on this Square
so let's just babysit this for a second
play a bit faster
let's go with this
that move
it might be there
okay let's go with this
and this
be defending the night
I'm also on F6
okay they resigned I'll see yeah I was
on F6 I was on a lot of stuff there it's
ready to take the Knight if I would
remember it the night was hanging after
I took the pawn on G4
all right one more game will count for
the tournament
okay
who's in first
Lopez chess man is great
okay how about
E4 E5 game
scotch
and he takes Knight
Bishop is hanging there
castles and
take towards the center
they're going to give me the a file
no a file let's play in the center
and also threatening a fork
I like my position
okay
is white asking for some trouble might
be
F4
necessary
but then there's these ideas D4 and then
anchoring a knight in there
I think I'm gonna go for that
Step One Stop castling I guess
Queen on H4 G3
sure how I feel about that
I could just play this one though
still and
drop back with my knight to H6 when
questioned
hmm
yeah I want to keep this here I don't
know what I like about him giving up
that E4 Square I'm going to play with
this
look to break up this E5 Pawn
I'm not thrilled about my night post but
all right
here we are
if Queen side Castle
maybe this guy is going to be a nuisance
someday
let me already start with some
some play here that's looking to
question the night although they're not
reacting to that
all right let's start with the let's
start with the capture right now
and then give this Knight a shove
so where to go going back home we're
going to E2 this was this could fall
I don't know if I even want to take the
pawn on H on A2
yeah I think I want to preserve my B4
Pawn
I think the king is going to be
comfortable there let's hang on to this
Center
maybe even think about C4 although right
now it's not quite there because the
battery this bishop takes C4 need to
move this guy first
okay
I don't know if that's really
I think that's that's helping me oh I'm
missing that there's that move
okay
well I guess now we're we're taking here
or
I could have gone for a skewer
missing a lot of stuff
should still be better
King B1 there's B3
threatening a skewer here
maybe double the Rooks
okay so I have a second chance let's not
miss the second chance at the skewer and
it should be a full Rook actually
because there isn't a way to connect the
Rooks
even on the clock
okay
grab the material
grab the material
pin the night
um
so I usually go here stop and night jump
this last couple
actually what am I doing
this was not the best play
my Rook was ready to get trapped
not good
all right
have that Nifty move defending
everything
as we just push
break their King here everything should
be fine
night checking takes Pawn
no mates
another
not a skewer but a fork this time around
got a main threat
soon
don't watch out for stalemates
have too much material here
would have would have liked a little
less material okay I guess we're not
even gonna get gonna get that final
pairing
that's gonna do it
as the clock winds down a minute left
all right how many games we got in there
eight games
he's always fly by
about a 50 minute tournament for me
all right
good game's all I'll just wait it out
these final seconds see who
ends up in first
second and third
this guy had a nice result
13 games
top three
yeah
oh that came finished oh it's up to 45
now
447 in there
confetti
not for me
finished in 19th
okay there's your top three
top ten let's look at the top 50.
who else was playing in this event
top 40.
top 50. all right I'm gonna call it
there again just a quick video another
Blitz tournament the mic is
working just fine it seems so
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback in the comment section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away that's all for now
take care bye